dès demain je serai sur le terrain pour
convaincre les français de voter
françois fillon c'est le seul qui pourra
vraiment remettre la france à niveau je
souhaite bonne chance
enfin à notre conseil national qui se
tient aujourd'hui je suis sûr que nous
sommes extrêmement nombreux et que nous
allons prouver que la droite est en
ordre de bataille
rassembler et réconcilier et que nous
allons gagner toutes les échéances de
2010 est en juin prochain offrant notre
candidat françois fillon le prochain
président de la république une majorité
large et solide pour redresser notre
pays
je sais pouvoir compter sur chacun
d'entre vous alors en route pour la
victoire en route pour la reconquête de
nos territoires bien j'ai envie de dire
que notre pays a besoin également d'un
fort redressement et si je peux aux
côtés de françois fillon de son prochain
gouvernement
apporter mon expérience au redressement
de la france pour que nos compatriotes
doivent de nouveau fier d'être français
c'est notre premier conseil national
depuis les primaires
donc nous allons aujourd'hui toute la
famille ensemble réunit discuter
échanger et bien entendu je n'en doute
pas un seul instant nous serons tous
ensemble unis derrière françois fillon
pour pouvoir lui permettre d'être
d'autres prochain présent la république
aumôniers nous devons nous mobiliser
pour réussir l'alternance autour de
françois fillon et donc devrait de
toutes nos forces pour redonner l'espoir
aux français et réaffirmé notre unité
nationale pour une france fière et
fraternelle
[Musique]